EIGHT TIMES THEY PLAYED EACH
OTHER LASTE, SETS UP
PATTERSON AND BEHIND SORS.
HE GETS A SOROKIN.
IF YOU DON'T WAKE UP IN A HURRY,
YOU'LL
GOALTENDER AND OUT TO THE SLOT.
CROSBY TO Le LANGUAGE.
OFF A
THIS TYPE OF START, IT'S A
OUTSCORED THEIR OPPONENTS OD FO.
ISLANDERS HAVE NOT WON A GAME
THEY ALLOWED THE FIRST GOAL,
SOROKIN.
>> Butch: LITTLE THINGS
ISLANDERS AREPORTUNITY.O D TO D
THAT  WON 4 OUT OF 5
FACE-OFFS.
CIZIKAS TAKESHER.
AHO A WRIST CE
AND ESPECIALLY NOW.
NO SUCH THING AS A TWO-LINE
IT TO
HIM AND KAPANEN SCORES!
GOOD PLAY BY CROSBY TO SLIDE IT
THE ICE. RIGHT.
FAR SIDE.
RUHWEDEL AND CIZIKAS
THERE IS E ON THE ICE
AND SEE IF THEY CAN CATCH THE
SECOND HALF OF THE POWER PLAY IS
AND CIZIKAS PULLED IT TO THE
BACKSE TWO GUYS OUT AND
IT WILL HAVE AN EFFECT ON YOUR
POWER PLAY, NO DOUBT ABOUT IN C
ABLE TO GATHER IT IN.
LOOKS LIKE CROSBY NEED THEM.
>> Brendan: OFF A SET PLAY FROM
THE FACE-OFF AND A FACE-OFF.
CROSBY AND CARTER OUT THERE.
TWSTICK.
SETS UP WAHLSTROM AND GETS IT
OPPORTUNITIES AND WHAT
THEY WANT.
THEY HAVE CERTAIN EXPECTATIONS.
THEN
>> Brendan: ISLANDERS SENT OUT
THE ITEM LINE. OF ACTION
IN FRONT OF THAT NET. ICECE
ISLALA IT.
SETUP FOR STICKLESS BLUEGER.
DOBSON'S SHOT SAVE AND MADE
REBOUND WON'T'T A SAVE THAT WAS.
HE
HOGED HI
HOLDING HIS LEFT ARM AS THE